l'énergie renouvelable maintenant
l'europe cherche de nouvelles façons de
produire de l'électricité l'énergie des
océans et par exemple totalement
sous-exploité et bien au danemark en
norvège deux nouvelles vidéos sont en
train d'aboutir pour mieux utiliser
cette ressource inépuisable qui ne
produit ni les chais nucléaire ni gaz à
effet de serre et en plus c'est
l'occasion d'admirer des paysages
somptueux agnès non 2 et nathalie gallet
utiliser la puissance l'énergie des
vagues
un vieux rêve auquel les hommes pensent
depuis longtemps sans avoir vraiment les
moyens de le concrétiser
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est fait au large
du danemark
des chercheurs financés par l'europe aux
mises au point un étrange prototype il
machin flottante de 2 137 tonnes baptisé
les travaux des vagues
le principe est relativement simple
c'est la capture de l'énergie des vagues
les vagues sont canalisés elles doivent
rouler sensibilise elle grimpe sur une
rampe homme est tombé dans une poule où
est stocké l'eau s'écoule ensuite dans
des turbines
la pression permet de les faire tourner
et de fabriquer de l'électricité comme
pour un barrage classique simple mais
dans ce laboratoire à munich il a fallu
tout imaginer les tempêtes les vents
violents l'arrivée de grosses où de
petites vagues ce qui a pris plus de 10
ans de recherche
aujourd'hui ce prototype alimente près
de dix mille habitations dans deux ans
de plus grosses usines seront
construites
de nombreux pays qui ont suffisamment de
vent et de vagues pourront alors son
équipe et nous pouvons sans déranger les
activités de pêche où le trafic des
bateaux produire jusqu'à 20% de la
consommation de toutes leurs heures
il suffit de le faire donc construire 1
puis un autre et encore un audrey pour
faire baisser les prix encore les
projets pour utiliser la mer sont en
fait de plus en plus nombreux en norvège
par exemple des éoliennes entrée à 50
mètres de profondeur tout avec les
courants marins
certes ces prototypes n'en sont qu'à
leurs débuts mais dans cette quête de
nouvelles énergies forcément propre les
océans devrait jouer un rôle important